[Music]
stay back stay back
second time is the harm for these rotten
remakes proving that some movies are so
nice no need to make them twice honestly
there are so many remakes these days
it's kind of hard to keep count
especially in the horror genre I mean
why do we insist on remaking so many
International films when they're great
on their own
hello how are the children
each of the critically trash films on
this list scored less than 10 on the
Tomato Meter so these are the biggest
misses among misguided movie Ventures so
brace yourselves friends as we count
down the worst reviewed remakes ever
[Music]
number 10 When a Stranger Calls
far away from the sight of a gruesome
murder a teenager named Jill Johnson
arrives at a luxurious home for a
babysitting job when the children are
fast asleep she settles in for what she
expects to be an ordinary evening soon
the phone rings and the frightening
words of a sadistic caller turned Joe's
routine experience into a night of
Terror starring Camila Bell Tommy
Flanagan Tessa Thompson and directed by
Simon West critics say When a Stranger
Calls ranks among the more misguided
remakes in Horror history offering
little more than a rote largely
fright-free update to the original
laughs
Rosa
foreign
[Music]
number nine Bangkok Dangerous
remorseless assassin Joe is in Thailand
to complete a series of contract
killings for a crime boss called siren
now he hires a street Punk named Khan to
run errands for him all the while
planning to kill the youth at the
conclusion of his assignment instead Joe
becomes Kong's unlikely mentor and
begins a tentative romance with the
local shop girl but as Joe begins to let
his guard down sarit decides it's time
to clean house starring Nicholas Cage
shakrit yamnarm Charlie young and
directed by oxide and Danny Peng critics
say with murky cinematography a
Meandering Pace a doll storyline and
rather wooden performances the Ping
Brothers is Hollywood remake of Bangkok
Dangerous is unsuccessful
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
number eight Yours Mine and Ours
when Coast Guard Admiral Frank Beardsley
decides to move his family of eight
children back to his old Hometown he
encounters handbag designer Helen North
an old flame from high school
immediately Sparks Fly between the two
and marriage is proposed but Frank isn't
the only one with kids to worry about
Helen has a total of 10. and together
they decide to sabotage their parents's
relationship starring Dennis Quaid Renee
Russo Danielle Panabaker and directed by
Raja Gosnell critics say the initial
setup for Yours Mine and Ours is
unbelievable the plotting is predictable
and stale and the comedy depends on
repetitive Pratt Falls that soon get old
we are all going to sail it working
together like the many tentacles of an
octopus Guided by one brain
my children have separate brains Frank
it's just a figure of speech
okay
one hour let's see together gonna be
best friends
okay prepare to come about
coming about come on
wasn't anybody listening when I gave my
briefing about standard nautical
procedure I have sunscreen in my eyes oh
well let's go below we'll wash it out
William Take the Wheel all right sir
this is munion you have the kids no
problem
get that camera away from me but I'm
capturing the Verity of Life at Sea how
about capturing my fish in your face
[Music]
doesn't smell like water I'm gonna go
tell our dad I'm gonna tell my mom
number seven Jacob's Ladder
after losing his brother in combat Jacob
singer returns home from Afghanistan
only to be pulled into a mind-twisting
state of paranoia singer soon realizes
that his sibling is alive but life is
not what it seems starring Michael Ealy
Jesse Williams Nicole the hair and
directed by David M Rosenthal critics
say a needless remake that quickly loses
sight of the themes that elevated the
original this is a Jacob's Ladder that
leads straight to nowhere
foreign
come on
what do you want
they're getting myself
number six Swept Away
imagine being Shipwrecked on a beautiful
island with someone you just really
can't stand a young Soldier is cast
adrift on an island with his employer a
rich self-centered woman who is used to
having her own way cut off from society
he reverses their roles stripping her
pride and vanity and controlling her
completely until that is she falls in
love with him starring Madonna Adriano
Gianni Gene Tripplehorn and directed by
Guy Ritchie critics say muddled and
lacking the political contacts of the
original Swept Away offers further proof
that Madonna can't act
the advantages of chemicals are all
around
do we have to listen to that again four
thousand uh hold on what happened we're
playing for 28 an ounce
it's four thousand it's a problem
Michael don't you think I'm good for it
Tony can't you control your wife can't
you control yours it's a change the
atmosphere just a little you're supposed
to be Mr Moneybags Michael I am supposed
to be on vacation
stop being such a [ __ ] Michael
come on come on if you haven't got money
I'll take jewelry and shoes that's
enough I fold I have no interest in
playing get quick with uh Mel DeMarcos
here
Guido
yes mother when you put that reptile
down can you empty the ashtrays
thank you so go on chemicals advantages
where would we be without fertile
well you should ask Pepe he was a
full-time fisherman till pollution
putting into that
Sam what he thinks about chemicals
nothing wrong with chemicals well Pepe
what do you think about it what do you
think about fertilizers and pesticides
whatever number five the fog
the prosperous town of Antonio Bay
Oregon is born in blood as the town's
Founders get their money by murdering a
colony of lepers but the truth of what
they did is concealed from subsequent
Generations more than 100 years later
Elizabeth Williams whose family lives in
Antonio Bay returns just as a statue in
tribute to the founders is to be
unveiled now when a mysterious fog rolls
in Elizabeth and her boyfriend soon
Discover it has vengeful Supernatural
Powers starring Tom Welling Maggie Grace
Selma Blair and directed by Rupert
Wainwright critics say the fog is a
so-so remake of a so-so movie lacking
scares suspense or originality
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
number four flatliners
five medical students embark on a daring
and dangerous experiment to gain insight
into the mystery of what lies beyond the
confines of Life the bold adventure
begins when they trigger near-death
experiences by stopping their hearts for
short periods of time now as their
trials become more perilous each must
confront the sins from their past while
facing the Paranormal consequences of
journeying to the other side starring
Elliot page Diego Luna Nina Dobrev and
directed by Niels Arden opplev critics
say flatliners Falls flat as a horror
movie and fails to improve upon its
source material rendering this reboot
Dead on Arrival
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
go go go go
can you hear me
crazy you know that number three kite
with the help of her father's ex-partner
and a friend from her past an orphan
teen mercilessly blasts her way through
a dark milieu in pursuit of her parents
Killers starring India Eisley Callan
McAuliffe Samuel L Jackson and directed
by Ralph zeiman Kyle Smith from the New
York Post says a kill a minute gorathon
whose twist is so obvious your grandma
Edna will see it coming kite never gets
off the ground
okay
let's get the girls and get out of here
come on
jump me take the girls
the littles be promised to Starkey you
want one you cash with him
who is staggy Starkey stains
deluate you come back later they got one
eye he cashed you cheap
what do you mean one eye
just like starki he make them look like
he got
yeah so
if I say we're out of time fella
ah
a
okay come on let's go go
number two Cabin Fever
fresh out of college five friends face
the horrors of a flesh-eating virus
while staying at a remote cabin starring
Nadine Crocker Matthew Daddario Samuel
Davis and directed by Travis Z critics
say no need to quarantine for Cabin
Fever enthusiasm for this inert remake
is not contagious
look up
I can burn
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
and of course before we reveal number
one here are some honorable mentions
shutter
photographer Ben and his new bride Jane
turned their honeymoon into a working
vacation when he snags a prestigious
assignment in Japan now as they make
their way up a Mountain Road at night
they slam into a woman who suddenly
appears in their path unable to find her
body Ben and Jane continue onwards soon
Eerie reminders of the accident emerge
when Ben sees ghostly images in the
photographs that he develops starring
Joshua Jackson Rachel Taylor magumi
okina and directed by masayuki Ochi AI
critics say being a remake of a Thai
horror film instead of Japanese doesn't
prevent shutter from being another lame
Asian horror remake
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're gonna stop
martyrs
with help from a friend a tormented
woman tracks down the family that
imprisoned and tortured her when she was
a child starring Troian Bellisario
Bailey Noble Kate Burton and directed by
Kevin and Michael goats critics say
Martyrs flays off everything that gave
the original its icy horrific Beauty
leaving us in empty pointless remake
foreign
foreign
[Music]
and finally number one One Missed Call
when Beth Raymond Witnesses the deaths
of two friends she knows there's more at
work than just a tragic coincidence days
before they die both victims hear their
terrifying final moments on cell phones
now though the police think Beth is
crazy detective Jack Andrews believes
her together the pair try to unravel the
mystery behind the horrifying messages
before their own phone numbers come up
starring Shannon Sossaman Ed Burns Anna
Claudia talancon and directed by Eric
bellette critics say one of the weakest
entries in the J horror remake
sweepstakes One Missed Call is undone by
Bland performances and Shop worn shocks
thank you
Luna
[Music]
Luna
[Music]
foreign
that about does it for us be sure to
stay tuned to the Rotten Tomatoes
channel for more of the entertainment
content you love and for even more news
scores and recommendations on the latest
TV shows and movies Go to
rottentomatoes.com until next time I am
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]